et bien ce petit livre de george
friedman à 100 pages et c'est un livre
extrêmement coup et il porte un titre
qui est un titre un peu austère pourtant
je crois que malgré ce titre il est
d'une brûlante actualité c'est 100 pages
valent beaucoup l'autre pas george
friedman son auteur qui est directeur
d'études à la sorbonne est un sociologue
spécialisé en particulier dans les
problèmes du genre dans les rapports
entre la technique et l'humain et il a
écrit en 1938 il ya une vingtaine
d'années par conséquent cela un petit
livre également qui comportait assez peu
de pages sur l'urss qui était aussi un
livre assez austère et qu'on a considéré
à juste titre comme prophétique et il
est probable que ce petit livre qu'il
publie aujourd'hui qu'il consacre cette
fois l'amérique latine est aussi un
livre prophétique à l'amérique latine
quand on s'occupe assez peu en général
en europe on n'est peut-être pas
tellement tourné vers ce continent est
un continent qui vraisemblablement fera
parler de lui dans les années qui
viennent est d'ailleurs l'un a parlé
vous le savez en commençant par les déjà
ce mois ci et les semaines qui viennent
de passer puisqu'il s'est produit un
certain nombre d'événements à l'amérique
du sud qu'il ya une espèce de crise
permanente à la mairie et bien george
friedman à la fois un économiste en
sociologue et spécialiste des problèmes
du travail un homme aussi qui a voyagé à
plusieurs reprises à l'amérique du sud à
tenter de réunir dans ce petit livre les
clés en somme des problèmes essentiels
vous disiez donc monsieur freeman qui
nous et qu'ils allaient là bas pour
fonder une section de sociologie du
travail au chili et ensuite en 1958
l'année dernière je fais un second
séjour pour la faculté latino américaine
des sciences sociales qui est une
institution extrêmement intéressante
crée d'abord par l'unesco et ensuite
soutenu par les 22 états de l'amérique
latine afin de former des professeurs
d'université dans les différentes
sciences sociales parce que voyez vous
n'est ce pas je crois répondre à votre
question
l'amérique latine est un continent
soumis à des changements extrêmement
rapide et vous me demandez tout à
l'heure sans doute les remèdes pour les
crises de ce continent est bien des
premiers remède pour les hommes de
l'amérique latine c'est de connaître
ceux ci il se brasse chez eux de
connaître leurs problèmes afin de
pouvoir s'y adapter et alors cette
faculté qui est créé à santiago parce
que le climat de santiago est vraiment
très agréable et que d'ailleurs les
chiliens appelle désormais santiago la
genèse l'amérique latine à cause du
nombre d'institutions internationales
qui s'y trouve bien cette faculté
latino-américaine est je crois une
grande entreprise pionnière qui aidera
latino américains à se connaître et à
s'adapter
il n'existe pas lier d'entreprise de ce
genre à l'europe on dirait qu'on a
peut-être moins besoin que on a appelé
l'amérique du sud
en tout cas certains de ces pays mais je
crois qu'on peut appliquer l'expression
à l'ensemble c'est ce que vous faites
dans votre livre le pays des contrastes
oui en effet roger bastide a écrit en
particulier un très beau livre qui
s'appelle brésil terre des contrastes
mais voyez-vous j'en ai fait j'ai pas
mal voyagé et j'ai été frappé en
amérique latine par le nombre et
l'omniprésente et contraste contraste
entre ces villes immenses comme par
exemple buenos aires qui est maintenant
une agglomération de près de 7 millions
d'habitants
d'une part donc entre ces villes
immenses comme buenos aires comme saint
paul comme belo horizonte qui a doublé
en quelques années est par ailleurs la
nature vierge qui est qui s'étend
presque aux portes de ces villes est par
ailleurs aussi il faut dire ces
quartiers pauvres
c'est sorte de bidonville qui existent
en marge de toutes ces agglomérations
qui ont des noms pittoresques on les
appelle les kayhan paso j'utilise ces
femmes lg face à l'as à rio les
corticaux les villas semi arias à buenos
aires où il ya déjà là par conséquent
prennent mans des contrastes étonnants
et puis alors il ya les contrastes entre
ces immenses
une qu'on a créée avec des capitaux
européens ou nord américains ces grandes
aciéries au pérou j'étais au pérou aussi
au chili ou au brésil
contraste entre ses usines ultramodernes
et alors les lieux où vivent les
ouvriers contraste entre ces lieux ultra
moderne et le grouillement des
populations dans la nous trouvons un
thème que j'ai cherché à marquer dans ce
livre parce qu'il a été pour moi une
découverte
c'est le grouillement des populations de
l'amérique latine par exemple dont ces
villes comme talcahuano un port de sur
le pacifique en port chilien
vous voyez d'esclaves autour du port des
centaines des milliers d'enfants qui
vivent dans des quartiers misérables ou
encore aux charbonnages de l'ôta ou
également vous avez des enfants qui sont
dans cette misère et dont les études
montrent que seulement un quart d'entre
eux ont une chance de quitter ces
communautés nous sommes là immédiatement
dans ce problème démographique et enfin
un dernier contraste si vous voulez
alors qui est extrêmement frappant pour
nous eh bien c'est seulement en amérique
latine
je dois dire que j'ai vu des quartiers
qui m'ont inspiré le sentiment de la
beauté architecturale
c'est en amérique latine que nos grands
l'architecte comme le corbusier ont
réussi leurs plus belles réalisations
c'est dans des villes comme rio comme
santos comme belo horizonte que vous
voyez vraiment ce que l' architecture
moderne peut faire et en quoi elle peut
créer de nouveaux horizons de beauté oui
je crois qu une des choses les plus
importantes qui apparaît dans votre
livre et dont on a le moins conscience à
l'europe c'est que l'amérique du sud
finalement est un continent sous
développés lorsque nous connaissons
maintenant ce terme et lorsque nous
l'employons nous pensons à l'afrique
nous pensons
l'asie ou à certaines portions de l'asie
on pense rarement l'amérique du sud et
je crois que ce qui est nouveau dans
votre livre c'est ceci justement et
c'est que peut-être que les problèmes
que va avoir affronté l'amérique du sud
dans l'avenir sont typiquement les
problèmes ce que vous appelez vous le
tiers-monde où ils sont les facteurs de
ce tiers mais bien ceux tiers-monde de
se passer le titre de vivre remarquables
qui a été édité sous médiation de balan
lier ce terme on le comprend en effet
les populations d'asie des populations
d'afrique des populations de divers
continents
il comprend aussi ces populations
l'amérique latine qui en font partie
pour un certain nombre de raisons
d'abord il ya cette augmentation
extraordinaire de population je dois
vous dire que j'ignorais tout cela avant
d'aller en amérique latine j'ignorais
par exemple quand l'amérique latine le
taux d'accroissement de la population
est le plus élevé du mouvement il est de
2 5% c'est-à-dire que chaque année là où
il y avait 100 individus 100 latino
américains et bien à la fin de l'année
il y en a si j'ose dire deux ennemis de
plus les spas et si vous voulez chiffres
et ça pour le brésil où l'augmentation
est très spectaculaire
le brésil qui a environ 62 à 63 millions
d'habitants à ce moment augmente chaque
année de près de deux millions
d'habitants et on compte que si ce
rythme coupe faim se prolonge
l'amérique latine aura un demi milliard
d'habitants à l'an 2000 oui alors c'est
extrêmement grave parce que les
investissements qu'on fait pas l'argent
qu'on investit là bas sert en partie a
donné de quoi vivre et je dirais enfin
misérablement souvent à ses millions et
ses millions d'êtres qui naissent
mais c'est à dire que cela retarde
d'autant l'élévation du niveau de vie du
pays ça retarde d'autant
il est par ailleurs ça pose une question
que je peux seulement évoqué ici
lui qui se trouve tragiquement poser
quand on voyait la mecques latine
la question du contrôle des naissances
et puis alors il ya aussi un autre
aspect de ce tiers monde au sujet du
kaloum interrogiez cette
industrialisation tellement rapide
tellement tellement désordonnée
oui où ce sont des pays de changement je
disais d'un rythme extraordinaire et
alors on crée des usines ont créé des
industries nouvelles il n'y a pas de
politique coordonnée par exemple au
chili un exemple enfin que je suis parce
qu'il est frappant il ya huit usines de
frigidaires dans ce pays immense spa il
ya 4500 kilomètres de côtes basses à 8
millions d'habitants seulement et ses
huit usines produisent par an en tout
huit mille frigidaire télé avril et mai
il chaque huile chacun veut que tout de
même une usine suffiraient pas et alors
que par exemple n'y a pas assez
d'énergie électrique ni en argentine ni
aussi dit dans ces différents pays
oui donc d'où l'existence de masse de
population flottante une sorte de sous
prolétariat semi-rural semi industriel
sur lequel vous attirez l'attention dans
votre livre parce qu il explique je
crois les mouvements politiques de ces
dernières années dans les pays
d'amérique du sud
en effet le pas ce sont ces centaines de
milliers ces millions d'aix paysans de
gens nés à la campagne ou fils de paysan
précipiter dans les villes dans le
buenos aires par exemple à sao paulo
dans les villes brésil au chili qui
explique une grande partie des désordres
et des problèmes latino américains j'ai
ainsi compris là bas que le phénomène du
péronisme et inexplicable et vous avez
vu ces jours ci car ces questions sont
d'une actualité brûlante qui a eu de
grands désordres en argentine
l'argentine est gouverné en ce moment
par un homme extrêmement habile spam et
qui doit vraiment être un danseur de
cordes politique c'est le président à
retour au franc ni zee qui doit
gouverner un pays où les observateurs
considèrent que environ 11% des
électeurs sont restés des personnes
n'est ce pas attiré par ce mythe
extraordinaire ne peut pas parler
mauvais summit conjointe de deutsche
bahn et des vitrages dont
vannes est exilé mais il continue
d'attirer enfin l'attention des gens et
vita est morte mais quantité des
milliers d'argentins pense encore à elle
et le péronisme et inexplicable comme du
reste l'est l'eugénisme monde réside
quelles sont les solutions eh bien les
solutions de cette crise qui je crois
est une crise pas comme les autres
parlant que lorsqu'on parle avec des
gens qui vivent beaucoup en amérique
latine il vous dis-je m'enfin vous êtes
un néophyte vous croyez que le ccri ce
n'est pas comme eux il ya toujours eu
des cris des ces crises à mon avis est
mon diagnostic
c'est une crise pas comme les autres
puisqu'elle est chronique elle est
chronique elle elle applique des
désordres continuelle vous avez vu les
émeutes de ces jours ci à rio et en
argentine
vous demandez quels sont les revenus je
voulais dire rapidement les remèdes
c'est le contrôle des naissances
c'est le marché comme il est
indispensable que c'est les états latino
américains ne continue pas de tirer à
hue et à dia n'est ce pas il faut qu'ils
coordonnent leurs investissements qui
coordonne les exportations de grosses
difficultés
certainement parce que d'abord il ya une
amérique espagnole et une amérique
portugaise que le brésil a un immense
sentiment de sa puissance et que je
crois en effet que c'est un pays qui
sera un des grands pays de la fin du
xxème siècle il ya des jalousies
il ya des discordes en particules entre
bleu brésil de l'argentine mais ils n'en
sortiront pas sans coordination et ils
n'en sortiront pas aussi sans une
assistance culturelle et technique c'est
à dire que doit non seulement faire des
investissements industriels mais aussi
former des spécialistes à porter je
dirais aussi enfin décidé à porter des
savants des humanistes le rôle de la
france ici peut être considérable oui
tout à fait si certaines ne sont pas
appliquées qu'elles sont reprochés si
monsieur frier bien hélas se doit dire
que là je
me réfère à enfin de grands connaisseurs
qui vivent là bas des gens que très
lucide pas bhl est bien mais prophétie
serait assez sombre je crois que si ces
rebelles ne sont pas appliquées eh bien
on verra les désordres s'amplifier on
verra les émeutes se multiplier et on
verra les différents pays faire appel à
des formes de nationalisme de fascisme
latino américains pour vous donner un
exemple enfin ou plutôt une image une
espèce de nasse air latino américains
qui réunit ray
les malheureux n'est ce pas là d'être
sous développés sous le drapeau de
l'amérique latine ou latino américains
mais enfin j'espère qu'ils n'en sera pas
ainsi je crois que les latino américains
doivent absolument se souvenir de ce mot
de wayne de louis qui n'est ce pas que
le monde soit 1 ou bien il n'y aura pas
de monde one world one world et mai
dernier mot tout de même serait dans ce
pays où je dois retourner chaque année
enfin ça serait d'amitié et d'espérance
je remercie je rappelle le titre de ce
livre qui encore une fois est très
lucide est claire je prends quelques
pages en une centaine de pages des
problèmes actuels de l'amérique du sud
et il s'appelle d'ailleurs problème
d'amérique du sud par george friedman il
a paru chez gallimard
[Musique]